foreign
contractors walked up these stairs and
straight through this window they had a
Court warrant to fit a prepayment meter
Louise a vulnerable single mother who's
asked to speak anonymously was not even
in debt I hadn't received any
notification they would come in I hadn't
received any letters I was paying my gas
and electric bill exactly you weren't in
debt I wasn't in debt no so I only found
out once I phoned up that and asked them
to look at my account how much money do
I owe how have we ended up in this
situation the call Handler said this 13
pound in credit on your account so we're
not sure what's happened here and how
did that make you feel
I still feel really violated about it I
I didn't know I just couldn't work out
how why they'd come in how they'd got in
once I realized how they'd got in we I
just felt really exposed really
vulnerable I still feel really
vulnerable because the window's still
broken
um and in embarrassing it's embarrassing
British gas acknowledged they made a
mistake with Louise and have ceased all
forced installations after the times
revealed debt collectors had forced
entry to the homes of vulnerable
customers regulator off gem has now
asked all suppliers to stop using
warrant while they investigated we spoke
to a current member of British gas's
debt recovery team there is a lot of
pressure put on that side of the
business to collect more debt to fit
more meters a lot of time looking if we
haven't fitted a meter why and looking
at what we can do better A lot of time
these customers that you speak to they
can't they physically can't pay they
don't have any money they can't afford
their energy so it's not about them not
wanting to pay they can't pay in a
statement British gas owner centrica
said it refuted his claim there has been
no increase in the number of prepayment
meters we have installed in the last 12
months fitting a prepayment meter under
warrant has always been a last resort
when a customer will not engage with us
despite multiple attempts over months
forced installation is supposed to be a
last resort for customers who refuse to
pay their energy bills but as prices
have soared tens of thousands of people
have been dragged into a bureaucratic
system that is plainly flawed the
question is if prepayment meters aren't
the answer to managing debt what is with
prices likely to stay high and millions
already in energy poverty it urgently
needs an answer Paul Kelso Sky News